(hip-hop music)
(engine revs)
♪ Run
(screaming)
♪ Run, run, run
♪ Ay, ay, ay, ay
- The baby's coming!
It's coming!
(yells)
(explosion)
♪ Oh dear, what the
fuck have we here
♪ These motherfuckers
all thorn no rose
- Let me smell your vagina.
(Woman screams)
♪ Better not sleep
(tires screech)
♪ Take a No-Doz, do some blow
(engine revs)
♪ Oh shit what the hell
♪ Have we done
♪ It's alive and
it's hungry as fuck
♪ Better hide all the
snacks and the dough
♪ But it's out of my control
♪ You are shit out of luck
♪ I don't wanna be
unfair but the pair
♪ We got beat that
♪ Weak shit you got true god
(coughs)
♪ Blew up the spot
with that new bop
♪ Crew drops, do up ya
squad without nuance
♪ I don't wanna
sound unkind but the
♪ Sounds I make are the sounds
(roars)
♪ Of the hounds that are howling
♪ Under the bed
(yells)
♪ I'm here growling
♪ Same time under the
blanket you're cowering
(roars)
♪ Cowering like
cowards cowering in
♪ Concrete showers
in Rikers Island
♪ Victims, we the wolves
(roars)
♪ That's wildling
♪ We often smile at
♪ sights of violence
(screaming)
♪ Acting brave and courageous
(crashing)
♪ Ain't advantageous
♪ For health and safety
(heart monitor beeping)
♪ So when we say
(yells)
♪ "Run the jewels"
♪ Just run 'em baby
♪ Please don't delay me
(yells)
♪ And that goes
for a guy or lady
♪ The fame goddamn
(squishing)
♪ We fuckin' crazy
♪ I'll pull this pistol
(shooting)
♪ Put it on your poodle
(screaming)
♪ Or your fuckin' baby
(shooting)
♪ She clutched the pearls
♪ Said, "What in the world!"
(glass breaking)
♪ And "I won't give up shit!"
(tearing)
(Roars)
♪ I put the pistol
(shooting)
♪ On that poodle
♪ And I shot that bitch
(shooting)
♪ Run the jewels, jewels
(popping)
♪ Jewels, jewels,
(breaks slam and glass breaks)
(smashing)
(slamming)
(squishing)
(gun cocks)
♪ Run the jewels, jewels
(heart monitor beeps)
♪ Jewels, jewels, jewels, jewels
(zombie moans)
(shooting)
(crashing)
(screaming)
(roaring)
(yelling)
(explosion)
♪ Run the jewels, jewels,
♪ Jewels, jewels,
(yells)
♪ Jewels, jewels
(laughing)
(explosion)
(stabbing)
♪ Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay,
♪ Ay, ay, ay